Và ninh dân trung gấp thành phố Phúc Châu tình Phúc kiến ngày 2018 tằng sống, tuyên án tự hình chào,
đối về ông Lưu dự tiến cửa quan chức trọng của Bộ Cấp Cào.
Bối tụi sang nhận hối lộ, hơn 1,2 mi trưởng như dân tệ,
tương đường người sống phải tảm chự đối là Mỹ.
Bà nán cho biết ông Lưu đã lợi dụng chúc vụ trong thời gian từ năm 2019,
đến năm 2019 không chăm hay người, để chục lợi trong nhiều lĩnh vực như kinhzoan tại chính và phải nợ.
Tua nhận định hành vi khám nhúng của ông Lưu người tổn thất đặc biệt nghiêm trọng, đến lỗi nhảm ước hình dân.
Tuy nhiên, rồi bị cáo thành khẩn khai báo, anh nâng hối cải và tựu vệ nộ g lại toàn bộ tài sản bất thật pháp.
Hình phà đưa chuyển tháng từ hình hoảng thi hàng án, hai năm.
Ông Lưu xin năm 2019, trong năm 2019, tệ khoảng tây từ giữa nhiều chức của quan trọng chức bộ cơm ăn.
Nơi bật với vái trời chỉ đạo phá vụ thậm xa số mề công, người chấn động năm 2019.
Hình thông trong mề mộ, năm 2019, ông đã trở thành ui viên trong cuộc mộ đầu tiên và duy nhất của Trung Quốc.